Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and Ben Wheatley
who’s directing the first two episodes of
Series 8 said that this year stories will
be much more like classic who, by which he
means dark and amazing.
I spent all last night thinking about walking
dead so now I’m imagining the tardis landing
inside the prison.
Doctor Who has done zombie stories by the
way.
Last week I also said I’d talk a little
about the things we learned from the out door
scenes peter capaldi and jenna louise coleman
filmed.
As always I’ll be picking the best questions
out of the comments to answer in my next Q&A
video, if you’re finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get it!
Don’t you just feel like everyone is going
to rush to netflix to start re-watching all
the old stuff now.
So here are 5 important takeaways from the
Wheatley’s Interview.
Number 5 - Think of Tom Baker’s run.
The tone of his run is specifically mentioned
and the season 15 finale invasion of time
when the fourth doctor left his companion
leela behind on gallifrey.
That was also one of the rare moments a doctor
broke the fourth wall and addressed the camera
directly.
Number 4 - Capaldi is a Scholar of Doctor
Who.
As opposed to Matt Smith who came to the role
with a completely fresh perspective, Capaldi
has been watching Doctor Who since he was
a little boy.
He even got to go on set and meet the Third
Doctor during his run.
He’s an amazing actor, so he won’t be
copying any of the classic doctor’s, but
I take his pre-existing knowledge of the series
to mean that we’ll see a lot of familiar
traits.
So if you see a little bit of your favorite
classic doctor’s in his performance, it’s
completely intentional.
Number 3 - Most recently Wheatley has been
working on horror stories.
J.G.
Ballad’s High Rise to be specific.
What does it tell you when Doctor Who is being
directed by someone enamoured with the 70s
horror genre?
That we’re going to get some old school
looking horror doctor who.
Or at least some really scary stories if not
outright horror.
Number 2 - Capaldi is still developing his
Doctor character.
Filming each episode happens fairly quickly,
so it doesn’t leave a lot of time beforehand
to completely develop his new persona.
So we’ll probably be seeing that happen
over the course of series 8.
It’s always a lot of fun to watch how different
Doctor’s have changed over the course of
their runs.
David Tennant and Matt Smith just kept getting
angrier and angrier.
So I can’t wait to see Capaldi finally explode.
Not literally.
and the number 1 takeaway He will be the darkest
doctor we’ve ever seen.
All the valeyard theorists will enjoy this,
even though I don’t think he’s the valeyard.
Whatever his performance ends up looking like,
he will essentially be the darkest scariest
version of the doctor we’ve ever seen.
That by itself sounds so exciting to me that
I think even the most loyal of classic who
fans will enjoy modern who.
Based on the idea of a really scary dark doctor,
let me know what kinds of stories you’d
like to see.
Think classic sci-fi horror.
I’ll be including my favorite comments in
my next Q&A video.
Now let’s talk about the big rumor we learned
last week from behind the scenes of Series
8.
Careful for spoilers if you don’t want to
know.
It was said that there was some dialogue between
capaldi and jenna louise coleman that implied
Matt Smith’s doctor had made a phone call
to himself in the future.
to Capaldi’s doctor.
It’s kind of meant to serve as an epilogue
for matt smith, like one final goodbye.
He doesn’t appear on screen.
So if it’s true, it would only be a voice
over cameo.
But it would make sense given the amount of
time Matt Smith spent talking to handles about
fixing the phone during the christmas special.
If there’s anything I think steven moffat
does really well, it’s paying off minor
story points in really big ways.
River Song was originally just a guest character
until Moffat magicked her into the character
she is now.
Let me know what you think about the idea
of Matt Smith having a voice over during the
series 8 premiere.
My next doctor who video will be a Q&A, so
be sure to subscribe to get it.
Walking Dead is coming back this sunday too.
Click here to check out my biggest questions
for season 4 this year and click here for
my doctor who series 8 predictions.
Thanks for watching.
See you tonight.
High Fives!